écoutez je suis
j'ai le trac de l'exciter
avec vous ce soir il a 20 ans j'ai eu
une crise de bonheur et petit à petit ça
m'a amené à comprendre que chacun
d'entre nous pouvait être un petit peu
de joie et de bonheur pour le monde
aujourd'hui nous sommes quinze mille
pourtant nous ne sommes pas une secte
je vais vous raconter l'histoire du
mouvement du bonheur citoyens et le
plutôt joyeuse alors lorsque j'avais 22
ans j'étais consultant en stratégie
j'adorais xl j'étais tout le temps
devant un excellent le plus beau
logiciel d jamais fait puis temps en
temps il m'arrive d'avoir un petit peu
chaud j'avais besoin de me lever
là gisait à mes camarades je sais pas ce
qui se passe mais là je suis super
heureux qui m'arrivait de rire quand je
me sentais un petit peu bête je sais pas
d'où ça venait et a priori
j'avais un déséquilibre biochimiques une
bipolarité mais juste le haut de la
courbe comme une dépression mais à
l'envers
alors je me suis dit je vais organiser
des dîners du bonheur pour comprendre
d'où ça vient donc avec thomas bénédicte
et ses 25 copains on faisait la
tambouille je mette une plus belle photo
est ce que c'est un tête quand même même
si c'est pas nous et nous voilà en train
de picoler en train d'explorer le
bonheur avec un speaker une fois tous
les quelques mois et à nous interroger
et puis une fois je me souviens ce
premier ce picard ruth ginhoven qui nous
a mis une claque du bonheur nous a dit
vous savez l'année la pire dans un
couple c'est l'année de la naissance du
premier enfant
waouh je reviens en avoir un un de ces
quatre avec nos ennemis ça fait mal et
en même temps en prenant du recul
effectivement cette année là on est au
four au moulin
on a moins de vie sociale on est un
petit peu de mal on n'arrive pas à tout
conjuguer ensemble et pourquoi est-ce
que je partage cet apprentissage
parce que je me suis dit évidemment il
s'agit pas pour autant statistiques à
l'appui de ne plus vouloir avoir
d'enfant mais puis tout se dire est ce
que en même temps que j'ai la joie
d'être parents je peux me préparer à
tous ces soubresauts de la vie et ses
heures
un jeune papa alors ce que j'ai appris
également à cette occasion
et bien c'est que la relation au bonheur
révèle quelque chose et je notamment ont
vu des gens qui m'ont dit ah non moi le
bonheur jamais ça ne m'intéresse pas
jamais et je me dis est ce que ça ne
cache pas quelque chose à l'image de
quelqu'un qui ne voudrait pas se
demander comment est ce que je vais dans
ma vie il ya un infirmier en centre de
soins palliatifs qui a fait une étude
incroyable qui s'appelle les regrets des
mourants elle s'est aperçue que le
premier regret lorsqu'on est sur le
point de mourir
c'est d'avoir vécu sa vie selon un
chemin tracé par d'autres est-ce que
s'interroger sur son bonheur n'est pas
un moyen de peut-être et bien prendre le
bon chemin et inversement
j'ai vu que de l'autre côté du spectre
vous aviez des gens qui avaient une
relation obsessionnelle au bonheur le
bonheur devient une obligation
et pourtant il ne devrait pas être cette
obsession et encore moins cette
injonction est à nouveau études à la
pluie les gens qui sont exagérément
préoccupés par leur bonheur et bien sont
moins heureux que les autres
un peu à l'image vous savez de ce livre
l'élégance du hérisson ou l'un des
personnages féminins
eh bien on organise une grande fête 20
ans pour fêter ses 20 ans de
psychanalyse est ce que je suis heureux
est-ce que je suis heureux est ce que je
suis en train d'être heureux est ce que
je suis en train de faire tout ce qu'il
faut pour être heureux non je pense que
la relation juste au bonheur c'est une
aspiration quelque chose qui nous guide
et cette idée a commencé à germer et je
me suis dit est-ce qu'on ne pourrait pas
amener cette aspiration dans la société
aux pouvoirs publics dans les écoles etc
et puis au cours de ces dîners ce qui a
été le déclencheur d'aller au delà de
ces rassemblements entre copains c'est
la découverte qu'il avait une science du
bonheur neurosciences psychologie
positive économie du bonheur toutes ses
connaissances et l'une d'entre elles m'a
marqué dans la vie les gens qui
accordent de l'importance à l'amour sont
plus heureux alors bon je suis marié à
quatre mois donc ça me va bien comme
information et pour autant en prenant du
recul on n'est pas en train de dire que
les gens qui sont amoureux ou
heureux dans leur couple sont plus
heureux dans la vie on est en train de
dire que les gens qui accordent de
l'importance à l'amour sont plus heureux
en d'autres termes le bonheur serait
liée aussi à l'endroit où je tourne mon
regard dans la vie et puis peut-être
qu'un déclencheur encore plus fort pour
agir au delà des dîners ça a été la
découverte du paradoxe dit stirling nos
nations sont arqueboutées dans la
génération de croissance économique
et pourtant en france entre 1973 et 2008
en 35 ans le pib a été multiplié par
deux hors inflation
et dans le même temps le niveau de
satisfaction des français auto déclaré
rester à 6 2 sur 10
ou est-ce qu'on a raté une marche et si
ton qu'on replace et le bonheur comme
une aspiration de notre société
alors on s'est rassemblés avec des
camarades au ans taverne en disant on va
monter un projet mais j'ai entre temps
reçu quelques remarques un peu musclée
de d'amis qui m'ont dit mon dieu
alexandre cette idée d'associations sur
des airs qui est ce que tu peux être
bête quand même c'est de l'eau tiède
ça n'a pas de fondement puis en un qui
m'a dit oh là ton idée de bonheur la
société c'est dangereux
et là je me six pièces on tient quelque
chose alors on a cherché un nom dans ce
café qui a brûlé depuis ça fait une
petite histoire comme ça et on a d'abord
imaginé saisi par des démons et bien
quelque chose de très clair catégorique
afp des associations de française pour
la promotion du bonheur ambiance années
80 boîtes de btp cogedim que j'ai frappe
puis on s'est dit non c'est parce qu'il
faut et si on était plutôt die monia le
bonheur en grec puis l'a1 en 36 15 un
peu coquin ça n'allait pas non plus et
puis on s'est rappelé que la france et
ce pays dans lequel est bien de toute
l'europe on accorde plus d'importance à
la hiérarchie au statut à la norme
donc on s'est nommé la fabrique spinoza
en hommage philosophe le think tank
laboratoire de réflexion du bonheur
citoyens et puis on a commencé à
conquérir nos maîtres de
noblesse en travaillant clos nul ocde
l'assemblée le parlement l'elysée
jusqu'à être nommé l'un des 12
principaux think tank français
et puis cette petite fierté c'est un
jour d'avoir remis un rapport auquel on
avait contribué à françois hollande sur
l'économie positive dans laquelle nous
avions une proposition qui était et si
nous changions la définition même d'une
entreprise
l'entreprise est un rassemblement de
personnes la bla bla virgule et qui
concourent à l'intérêt général
et si ce faisant en changeant la
définition d'une entreprise ont changé
le quotidien juridique et économique de
l'ensemble des français
et puis plus récemment notre source de
fierté est bien c'est d'avoir contribué
à une proposition de loi au sénat
cet été visant à instituer le conseil
parlementaire d'évaluation des
politiques publiques et du bien-être
en d'autres termes et si on faisait le
pari que chaque fois qu'une loi est
dessinée envisagée puis votée au
parlement
on s'interroge sur quelle est sa
conséquences exactes en termes de
bonheur sur les gens et si la loi sur
les 35 heures avait été envisagée en
terme économique mais aussi en termes de
bonheur pour les gens et puis arriver à
cette étape on s'est dit on à utilisent
notre tête mais ça n'est pas suffisant
nos rapports peuvent rester sur des
étagères on va donc aller plus loin et
agir utiliser notre corps fabriquer des
outils on a commencé à construire des
conférences du conseil des événements
apprenant des formations et l'une
d'entre elles qui me donne beaucoup de
fierté également
c'est l'université du bonheur au travail
120 personnes rassemblées pendant trois
jours et je revois cette femme en
entreprise assise dans un coin pensive
on s'approche d'elle en lui demande ce
que tu as bien elle répond de toute ma
vie je ne me suis jamais senti aussi
libre ou encore cette formation ou un
monsieur revenant dans son entreprise
simple collaborateur
bon pour être exact manager mais pas top
managers se dit eh bien je vais bâtir un
plan complet en douze pages
donc c'est la couverture qui l'amène à
son directeur général en dix ans nous
allons mener une politique pour
l'épanouissement des hommes dans mon
entreprise alors des milliers
d'entreprises auprès desquels nous avons
agi à nouveau nous donne la fierté et
pour autant on a commencé à se dire
qu'il manquait quelque chose qu entre
nous il y avait des frictions détention
et je me suis rappelé de cette pensée de
la luz est cela qui dit ne cherche pas à
impacter le monde tant que tu n'as pas
toi même grandi il fallait qu'on
commence à travailler sur nos comptes il
notre coeur et donc on s'est dit créons
des mini formation de communication non
violente pour apprendre à être
bienveillant entre nous et aujourd'hui
on ambitionne d'être devenu et bien une
communauté regardez ces jolis visages de
gens de la fabrique spinoza et on pense
on pense que ce faisant en nous
transformant nous mêmes nous pouvons
agir sur le monde est ce qui nous donne
foi en cela ce sont les neurones miroirs
ces fameux neurones qui font que lorsque
je transmets une émotion vous l'entendez
et vous la ressentez ce que le prix
nobel
golman appelle le wifi neuronale et qui
nous connecte
c'est tellement puissant comme phénomène
que si je suis heureux chiffres à
l'appui les gens autour de moi et même
les amis de mes amis ont eux mêmes plus
de probabilités d'être heureux pour
prendre un exemple de ça qui m'a inspiré
il ya une chaîne canadienne
tim hortons qui donne vendée café et
dont l'une de ses occasions
un client se voit dire qu'on lui a
offert le café que le client avant lui a
offert qu'est-ce qui décide de faire
il offre le café est le suivant aussi
combien de fois 228 fois de suite
est-ce que vous rendez compte delà du
potentiel de contagion positive alors
arrivé aujourd'hui nous nous disons la
chose suivante osant dire que nous
sommes le mouvement du bonheur citoyens
c'est cette femme qui nous a dit j'ai
découvert avec la fabrique spinoza que
je n'étais pas
pas seul à croire que il était possible
de favoriser le bonheur est aujourd'hui
est bien un mouvement pour nous c'est sa
tête le côté think tank ses actions ses
outils ses conférences le côté
propulsion et enfin le côté émotionnel
et coeur j'ai été chercher un texte de
act up dans un domaine très différents
qui m'a inspiré que j'ai un peut
paraphraser je vais le lire avec vous en
ce moment le pessimisme est une maladie
ensemble nous pouvons unir nos forces
pour résister à l'épidémie ensemble nous
pouvons construire une communauté
capable d'adopter une attitude positive
et constructive à la fabrique spinoza
nous avons choisi d'affirmer le bonheur
comme un défi vous pouvez le relever
avec nous aujourd'hui nous agissons dans
les champs de la démocratie de la santé
de l'éducation de l'égalité homme-femme
du travail et j'ai la joie de dire
vraiment nous sommes dans quatre pays
nous comptons une vingtaine de villes
mais surtout nous comptons mille passeur
du bonheur citoyens et mon invitation et
15000 amis mon invitation c'est la
suivante
vous n'êtes pas seuls rejoignez nous
rejoignez nous à votre capacité de
réflexion avec votre tête avec votre
corps vous outils en agissant ou alors
simplement en étant avec vos émotions et
ainsi soyez un petit bonheur pour le
monde et ce petit bonheur cette
étincelle est bien passé là je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
oh